all right alyssa
yeah alyssa where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
um grew up in um levittown in uh bucks
county pennsylvania
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad uh yeah i kind of
like a broken family growing up you know
um
mom and dad separate it and father was
kind of absent in my life most of the
time
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
i didn't really have much of a childhood
i kind of grew up really fast kind of
had to um like i took care of my
brothers a lot and
my mom was usually you know
out yeah
but no no abuse nothing like that going
on your childhood oh no like of course
there was you know um
i had a lot of abuse from
all different parts of my family you
know whether it was verbally or
physically but
you know and not sexually no never
sexually thank god
no kidding
and you went through high school
um yeah i actually i graduated high
school
um
that was uh i was living with my
grandmother um you know
my mom kicked me out when i was like 14
so
from 14 up i was
you know raised by my grandmother i'm
kick you out at 14.
uh she found out i was like smoking pot
and like got mad and
just me my mother never got along really
you know it was we never really had a
great relationship
so where'd you go at 14
um my grandmother's your grandmother on
my father's side um
so that that's where i like pretty much
did most of my growing up i guess you
could say
the drugs started for you at some point
well yeah well when i was 14 like i said
i started smoking pot and the harder
drugs drinking that didn't really start
until i hit my like 20s like early 20s
how do you know 30. you're 30. yeah
what did you start using in your 20s
uh it started with like pills like
percocet and you know stuff like that um
i went through a weird phase uh the one
summer when i was like 18 i smoked a lot
of pcp like all summer long but then
that stopped
but um like i didn't really i start with
a lot of hard
what does pcp do for you
they they call it they say like you're
walking on the moon like it's kind of
what it feels like like
it's it's really different um like you
almost feel like
like you're you're not there
i guess you could say like
like even when you look at the floor
it's like it looks like it's
30 feet lower than it actually is like
it's weird it's really weird to describe
what do you like about getting high
just
uh numbing myself really
escaping reality
from like what your rough childhood or
everything
like traumatic experiences of
you know being abused throughout my life
and
um you know
feeling anything
you have kids
i do
where are you kids
they're with family
i have three boys they do
and you're here in kensington yeah how
long you been here
about two years now
tell me about living on the streets in
kensington it's rough
you gotta have
pretty thick skin to
to be out there
um
it's probably one of the most dangerous
places you could live on the street it
feels like it
just driving around seeing the behavior
and that's not even half it's
it's way more in depth than what
everybody really sees at night it's got
to be really treacherous
yeah
you got to be careful where you step
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you
worst thing um
probably
just the men that are out there really
they're really uh
the only word i could really think to
describe is evil um
[Music]
you know i've had guns held to my head
i've been kidnapped i've
you know i've been raped like
that's probably the worst that's
happened
you know like i don't think it really
gets worse than that besides dying
and then you can't feel anything so
how do you make money
are you doing what a lot of the girls do
yeah yeah
what they call work and girl it's
prostitution it's the same thing yeah
i just like to make it sound nice
how does that affect you emotionally
it doesn't anymore
um
i kind of just uh turned it off
after a while you become numb to it it
gets you what you need
yeah
what is your what is your drug today
uh i do heroin and i like to smoke crack
heroin or fentanyl
it's fentanyl it's fentanyl and
tranquilizer is what it is which i'm not
a fan of the tranquilizer but
uh once you start doing it because they
put it in everything now um
you become it that's a whole other
addiction
what is the tranquilizer they put in it
like animal tranquilizer horse
tranquilizer
you know uh
cat trunk flies are like smaller animals
like cats and dogs
ketamine
you get addicted to that yes
in addition to all the other things here
that's a whole other addiction it's
probably this is probably
the worst withdrawal i've ever felt in
my life
i've never felt anything like it tell me
what withdrawal is like from these drugs
i mean like i've i've withdrawn from
heroin fentanyl cold turkey plenty of
times and it sucks it's really rough but
this is something else
people are dying from it from withdrawal
um
like i was in physical pain
when i was withdrawing from it like it
was that bad oh my god i it was bad
i couldn't stand it anymore and i've got
a pretty high pain tolerance you know
you don't particularly look like a
person that's living on the streets and
addicted to hard drugs yeah yeah a lot
of people say that
they don't even think that i get high
but i do
i mean like i try to keep
myself together i mean yeah you do a
great job after all it's kind of how i
have to make money anyways right
does your family know you're out here
yeah
what's their reaction to it
i mean
they say that they they care and they
don't want me to be out here and like
i'm breaking their heart but like you
know
nobody's ever made an attempt to come
and
find me or make sure that i'm okay or
go above and beyond to
you know go out of their way to help me
but if they did would you actually say
sure and jump in the car and get out of
here
now
probably yeah
i'm i'm just tired of this i am
like i've been coming to kensington and
getting high on and off for seven years
but i've been down here consecutively
for two years straight
you know like
it gets it gets old after a while like
it's really tiring
and you've odd before
uh twice in my life
um
once was
i mean they were both on accident i
never intentionally mentally kill myself
with it but i once was with like you
know
uh heroin and the other was a mixture of
pills i wasn't supposed to mix and i
didn't even know
but um
yeah i've been
i've done a
pretty good job of trying not to
go that far
with it you know like i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to kill myself or
anything
on purpose you know
they say that you're slowly killing
yourself which is kind of the truth but
you know
yeah some some of the
scenes you'll see in kensington it just
looks like these people have a death
wish
oh yeah
i mean i've spoken to a lot of people
that are like that but
you know when it really comes down to it
they changed their minds
do you sense that
over time your moral compass is just
being
changed or pushed
i definitely feel like it's being pushed
oh you're doing things that you just
normally would never ever consider doing
i mean yeah all your i never saw never
do that i'll never do this they all come
true
um
but i refuse to let this change me in
the simple like i'm not gonna stoop to
their level i'm not gonna hurt somebody
or rob somebody or
i just know what it feels like to be
done to me so i wouldn't want to do it
to anybody else yeah but if you look at
some of the
people that have been here for 10 15
years they're missing their teeth and
their skin doesn't look like yours does
and
and
they just start looking very disheveled
yeah they also decided not to take care
of themselves anymore either
people who have just given up hope and
lost all sense of reality
do you have friends
there's no friends in kensington
but if you want to call them friends do
you have anyone you trust
yeah
it's got to be lonely
sucks
i'd rather be alone than with somebody i
don't trust though yeah
have you ever been in love
have i ever been in love
yeah
before i started getting high and
everything yeah
when i was sober and actually happy yeah
but uh
there's no room for that right now
what emotions do you go through now
living here
oh
a lot of anger and sadness
not really happy moments you know
um
i kind of try and you know
kind of try and put that behind me a
little bit try not to let people
you know knock me off my square but
it's hard sometimes especially when you
get robbed like every day right
what does your typical day look like i
mean do you do you sleep
not really
but like you know in the early morning
what do you start doing and then how
does your day progress
i just get up and get myself together
and
you know go out and try and make a
little bit of money
get high
that's that's really all my day consists
of really and then it's just a routine
of running constantly running
then you're just trying to make money
for the next fix and over and over again
you're not saving anything of course
it's hard to save anything
and either i'm using it for what i need
because like i don't just spend all my
money on drugs like i buy clothes i buy
makeup i buy
hygiene products food like i you know i
mean like
i don't just spend every penny i have on
drugs but you know
it's hard to save money because
if i'm not spending it on the things i
need right then and i try to save it
it's getting robbed for me
you know there's not really
no way to save
money here
did you have to deal with pimps or
things like that
i have them approach me all the time
and they ask me to like work for them
they just say it in nice ways
try and convince me and talk me into it
by telling me they're gonna buy me all
this stuff and make all these empty
promises but you know i'm not an idiot
not naive
what do you worry about what are you
afraid of in your life
something i'm really afraid of anything
i just really don't want to face reality
like i know i'm probably facing jail
time when i when i finally stop running
if i finally stop running
um
and i just don't want to face it jail
time for what
stupid misdemeanor like possession
paraphernalia
stuff like that
never anything violent or anything
you're crazy
do you feel helpless against your drug
addiction
um
at the moment yeah
i feel like i can't stop right now
and like i don't want to
like they say that like you you're not
going to be able to get help unless you
got to want to you're going to want to
get help you got to want to stop but
like i don't
how do you get to that point
and your life now almost has no meaning
you're not raising your kids you're not
really doing anything except trying to
get a fix right and that's gonna leave
you feeling very empty
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
um
i think i would have um
probably finished school like i would
have went to college and did something
with my life
i wouldn't have
party like an animal i wouldn't have
jumped into things so quickly and
you know so abruptly in my life like i
just kind of
didn't think i just did things you know
instead of like thinking before i did
anything
and landed me in a lot of stuff
it seems like a lot of the people i
interview
especially the drug addict drug addicted
people
don't quite grasp the concept of delayed
gratification
oh everything's instant
they want to have their fun right now
if they want to spend their money if
they've got it they want to have fun
right now and there's no saving up for
the future right
how was the time you spent living this
life uh change you do you think
oh
[Music]
it just
it just kind of like it starts to take a
toll on you like you know like
i always said like it's like a different
species down here like these are human
beings these people have no
empathy no sympathy there's no morals
there's nothing like they're just like
they say it's like
just lost souls down here and
i've heard cops call it the land of oz
like it's crazy yeah it's a snake pit
yeah
you've got all the
hustlers
and con artists and
which are mostly the dealers and then
you've got all the people that are just
trying to survive
it's crazy because like people from all
over the world know about kensington
like
you can google it
and it's not just like oh it's a place
like it's like it's descriptive in the
sense of like
it's like known as the biggest heroin
capital in the world think of the world
that's crazy to think about
yeah it's pretty fascinating to drive
through the neighborhood
yeah
like needle park for example where
everyone's just hunched over or passed
out or looking like they're dead yeah
with a needle in their hand it's really
sick that they call it needle park
looks like mcpherson square park they
call it needle park yeah but there's if
you look on the ground there's thousands
of yeah discarded
beetles
people just like don't know how to live
anymore like
it's like they they become homeless and
they start
living worse than an animal would
i've never seen anything like in my life
it's hard to believe that humans exist
like this right
no roof over their head
no money
no friends and they're okay with it
abandoning their kids
and lives and careers i mean did you
have dreams of doing something when you
were young oh of course
what do you want to do
i want it i couldn't make my mind up
when i was younger i wanted to do all
kinds of different things
like down from
going in the medical field to you know
singing and and trying i don't know
there's just like a lot of different
things i wanted to do i couldn't make my
mind up
if you're still young you can still do
it
know
just not here on the streets right
what do you think the biggest factor was
in your life to to set you on this path
that got you here
i mean it's it's a disease man it's just
i mean we have a chemical imbalance in
our brain and can't help it you know
what i mean we're born this way and it's
so there are other addicts in your
family yeah
yeah my mother's an addict my father's
an addict
it's it
it's hereditary it's something that you
can't control you know just like if you
were to get cancer or diabetes it
sucks you feel like life is unfair
very
but you know
what are you gonna do life sucks
sometimes
not really anything you can do about it
you still have hope though
you look like you do yeah i mean
i know that if
when i'm ready or whatever i want to
get up and and
get my life together i can i've done it
a thousand times like
one more is not gonna do any
harm or damage it's just gonna make
things better
what was your favorite memory as a kid
um
i don't know if i really have a favorite
memory of being a kid
because i never was really i never
really had the chance to be a kid
what do you and the people that you hang
out with on the street talk about
i mean do you right yes just ever
everybody always right talk about drugs
and
like i like talking about other stuff
like i
you know like i'm actually down here
with my brother and like we hang out and
talk about movies and all kinds of
different things but like everybody else
just wants to talk about getting high or
getting drugs and
it's stupid like
you're already doing that like think
about something creative to at least
talk about you know
doing sex work for money has got to be
tough what are the customers
where they come from
they're not they're not drug addicts
right a lot of them are
a lot of them are yeah
um
a lot a lot of people are just really
i just really
like you really get to see how much they
really think a human life is worth
and it's really scary that these people
really think it's worth like nothing
scary
so the typical
date is a guy just rolls up in his car
picks you up and they you go to the car
date or you go to a hotel or where do
you go both
yeah
how much money will you make doing that
it depends
the average price that girls down here
make is like 40 or not
unless you're really just like a fiend
about it just even less you're going
less than that there's a lot of girls
who do
and then they make it harder for girls
like me and
that that don't that don't do that you
know what i mean like um
that's forty is pretty freaking low you
know what i mean like
to go lower than that like i would i
just can't i just can't
i think it's crazy
and do you get guys that want to do it
without a condom or oh they say that
[ __ ] all the time of course
of course
it's ridiculous
have you ever
in my in my past when i was younger
because this isn't my first time being
homeless out here like i was almost out
here when i was younger too and i was
like 22
23 i think but um
you know i'm not
young and dumb anymore like you know
that's
way too dangerous i would never
and you get guys that are asking strange
things
oh yeah all the time it looks like what
i know all kinds of stuff like there's a
lot of fetishes like guys have a lot of
fetishes out here that's the weirdest
thing you've been asked
um
oh god i don't even know um probably i i
still think the whole foot fetish thing
is weird like
there's a guy who picks girls up and
like wants to take pictures of her feet
and like
just the whole the whole
the whole act of it is it has to do with
like him touching your feet or your feet
on him or
pictures or you know what i mean like
it's weird and is there there's a
a sexual element for him in that yes
like he's he's turned on by it
just turned on by me then he climaxes
doing that or
uh yeah really yeah
there's another guy who's like got a a
smoking fetish
i don't want to say his name but um
you know he picks girls up
and he doesn't smoke cigarettes but like
he gets turned on by women who smoke
cigarettes so he makes them put lipstick
on
and
makes them blow cigarette smoke down his
throat
and like gets turned on by it while he
masturbates the entire time
and makes you role play
like
it's weird it's really weird
humans are strange aren't they yeah
yeah that's an understatement of her
down here
what's your biggest regret in your life
my biggest regret
having the opportunity to
turn things around before it got bad and
not doing so
and then losing everything
it's probably my biggest regret
knowing knowing what was gonna happen
and still continuing to do it
it's still not too late though
no
but if i keep going it will be yeah but
you're young you're still beautiful and
you can
you look healthy before you lose all
that
you just turn it around
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
this important lesson um
just don't take things for
like granted what you have while you
have it
cause like you might not have it
the next minute
all right alyssa thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck i hope you
got out of here thanks
thank you very much
you